let's start with episode 5 15
sadly shockingly dan dies
what was your reaction
[Laughter]
that was my reaction when you read the
script i mean were you kind of blown
away
do you feel like this was part of the
story that needed to be told
kind of walk me through the emotions
that you went through yeah absolutely
you know um
when it comes to when it comes to
situations like that where character is
going to be killed off
or you know go through a big change
those discussions start pretty early and
that's kind of what happened in this
process
but i was absolutely satisfied with what
everyone decided to do because i felt
that
it was a good idea to do because it was
just for story reasons
and character arc to where the audience
is just
getting to understand who this person is
and before they fully evolve
they're ripped out like ah you know and
i thought it was such a really good
choice and strong storytelling on their
part
he does pass while working on a case
with chloe
literally in her arms what was the
significance
of that do you think well you know
it was a true example of his art coming
full circle
right when when we meet dan he
is losing chloe he's losing her
but learning to coexist with her and
co-parent right and they've developed
throughout the arc of the several
seasons that we've done
a real genuine respect and a different
kind of love for each other so it just
made sense
for him to die in the arms of the one
person
who really truly understands who he is
you know
and i think it was very beautiful and it
was very difficult for both of us
to do that uh because we we do genuinely
love each other in real life yeah you
know so
it was uh it was it was a tough one i
got to tell you it was
everyone on that day was like i can't
believe this is
real tears ever speaking of tears i mean
everyone
is distraught by dan's death but
watching trixie
lose her dad for me was the most
heartbreaking
kind of talk to me about that and how
you think this will affect trixie
moving forward yeah you know um
it was it was everyone's reaction to
what happened to dan that really
makes that moment real right and uh you
know i personally have experienced the
loss of a parent and it's affected me
in a positive way you know it's
difficult but
and i think trixie the character of
trixie is the same way
yeah that all she'll remember are the
things that he taught her
that that he was trying to teach her and
take that and and
and gain a certain strength from it i
hope right
um but yeah and i think that's how
that's just sort of how they've evolved
who she is as a
human being that uh she's gonna come
away from it even stronger
aside from trixie what character do you
think will be most affected by this
no honestly i think the person who's
probably gonna be most affected by it
surprisingly probably lucifer wow
why do you say that i think because it
came out of nowhere
we were just starting to get better it
was ripped out from him as well
and i think you know with all the
characters in the show um
that was a genuine sort of start to
finish
sort of you know we're going one
direction and then it changes we're
going another direction and then it
changes and we can kind of keep coming
back around
and it was a really fully evolved sort
of what real relationships go through
i like you i don't i like you i don't i
love you maybe not so much
you know and i think i think it was
gonna i think it'll surprise him the
most
is he actually in hell and there's a
reason i'm asking this
is dan actually in hell why are you
asking this
well we learned that if you go to hell
it doesn't mean you necessarily stay in
hell
you can also go to heaven after that so
i'm just wondering
where dan actually is i don't know that
i can answer that question
okay i don't think i can answer that
question
maybe you can maybe you can answer this
then
is this the last we see of dan or is
part of the story i mean now that
lucifer
is technically seemingly god can he help
move dan that's a great question
actually it's definitely
not the last you're going to see it not
in the form
that everyone thinks you know it could
be through flashbacks it could be
through
trying to decide what's going on and man
you're
you're you're trapping me
i'm not trying to i just felt like no
it's a great question for that
and so to me i i just don't feel like
there's only one season left and dan is
such a big part of this world
and to have him not be part of season
six
seems so yeah
yeah well as you know you know i was on
set um
a little bit in season six so he's
definitely
just coming back
is this last then that we have seen of
him on earth
no okay that's a good that was a very
direct
answer i guess because you said that
lucifer is the most affected
and because of what we talked about with
the ability to move
from hell to heaven
does lucifer at all help dan i guess
deal with the guilt that he feels
because i guess if you don't let go of
guilt that's what puts you in hell so
kind of walk me through
that yeah that's that's great you know
but here's also the the
the thing we build
is that there really is no one who can
help you you have to help
you i think a lot of what what happens
with dan is
really just sort of lost in uh would
call it introspectively within himself
trying to figure out
his own uh demons so to speak and why
um you know why things happened to him
the way they did
um because it happened so abruptly right
right um
so that's that's what you'll find you'll
find
there is no help other than you helping
yourself basically what is he feeling
the most guilty about well that's just
it he doesn't know
it is that's the moment that things
explode in
this season okay so we'll get that
answer then
is there a world in which he gets some
sort of celestial power
yes no what would that look like no
no there's there's he doesn't you know
he's he's dan and i think one of the
things that i've loved about playing
this character and respected about the
writing is they've never changed him
from who he is
that's so true right so he's one of the
most consistent
people people in the show
yeah you know so i yeah i don't there is
there's no celestial
you know he's he is who he is and he
continues to struggle even through
through death what message do you have
for all the dan fans out there after
they watch five fights just remember
that i love you